Hallo, guten Tag. Hören Sie mich gut?
Ja, guten Tag Herr Doktor.
Vielen Dank.
Mein Name ist Tekra Meziola. Auf dieser Station als Arzt an Arzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne heute das Aufnahmegespräch mit Ihnen durchführen.
Alles in Ordnung für Sie?
Jetzt nicht. Deswegen bin ich hier Herr Doktor.
Ok. Und ja, sollen wir sofort anfangen.
So erst benötige ich ein paar Personen.
So können wir die Möglichkeit weiterführen.
Gerne Herr Doktor.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Henrike Meier.
Können Sie bitte einen Nachname langsam und deutlich buchstabieren?
Und meinen Nachname buchstabiert sich...
Ok, mehr, mehr. Vielen Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich bin 65 Jahre alt.
Fünfundsechsund...
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am zehnten Februar 1959 geboren.
Wie groß sind Sie Frau Meier?
Ich bin 1 Meter 76 groß.
1 Meter...
1 Meter?
Ja, 76.
76. Und wie viel wiegen Sie Frau Meier?
Ich wiege 86,6 Kilo.
86,6 Kilo.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Frau Meier, was für Sie zu uns? Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe seit etwa anderthalb Stunden starken Schwindel.
Es kommt so plötzlich, als würde alles schwanken.
Alles schwanken?
Ja.
Wie beschreiben Sie das?
Es fühlt sich an, als würde sich alles bewegen oder schwanken.
Ich kann das gar nicht richtig kontrollieren, Herr Doktor.
Alles dreht sich um Sie herum, wenn ich richtig verstanden habe.
Oder auf meinem Boot oder wie im Karussell.
Herr Doktor, ich kann nur so beschreiben.
Als würde sich alles bewegen oder wie Sie gesagt haben schwanken.
Ok, ok. Ich verstehe.
Seit anderthalb Stunden vorher haben Sie noch einige Beschwerden.
Wie Schwindel oder...
Das kann ich verstehen. Schwindel habe ich seit etwa zwei Jahren, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe das immer wieder.
Einmal pro Woche damals.
Aber in den letzten zwei Wochen ist es viel häufiger geworden.
Etwa viermal pro Woche, Herr Doktor.
Aber vorher?
Ja, damals, am Anfang meine ich.
Vor zwei Wochen oder bis vor zwei Wochen war es einmal pro Woche.
Aber seit zwei Wochen ist es viel häufiger geworden.
Vielmal pro Woche.
Ja, mit der Zeit meinen Sie, die Beschwerden wurden schlimmer geworden?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Herr Doktor, ehrlich gesagt, ich kann wirklich nicht mehr.
Ich arbeite in einer Bäckerei.
Diese Nacharbeit macht mich völlig fertig.
Und zu Hause ist auch alles so schwer.
Mein Mann ist arbeitslos. Ich muss mich um alles kümmern.
Und jetzt noch dieser Schwindel.
Ich habe einfach Angst, dass ich das nicht mehr schaffe.
Ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass Sie mich verstehen können.
Ich möchte wirklich in die Frührente gehen, Herr Doktor.
Ich halte das alles nicht mehr aus.
Ja, ich halte das auch nicht mehr aus.
Ich habe gehört, dass die Ärzte dafür zuständig sind.
Könnten Sie mir dabei helfen?
Ja, natürlich.
Frau Meier, zunächst sollen wir bis zum Ende des Aufnahmengesprächs führen.
Dann können wir ausführlich über dieses Thema sprechen.
Machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Darf Sie mir helfen?
Natürlich.
Danke.
Ich bitte Ihnen ein bisschen Geduld.
Und dann können wir nach dem Aufnahmengespräch wieder über dieses Thema sprechen.
Okay, wenn Sie mir dabei helfen können, kann ich darauf warten.
Kein Problem, Herr Doktor. Ich bin geduldig.
Okay, Sie sind Bäckerin.
Ich habe das alles notiert.
Frau Meier, sind die Beschwerden, diese Schwindel, langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten am Anfang?
Ja, wie gesagt, kommt es so plötzlich, Herr Doktor?
Aber Sie haben schon gesagt, seit zwei Jahren haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden.
Sie sind wie Attackanfälle, Herr Doktor.
Und alle Anfälle sind plötzlich aufgetreten.
Meinen Sie das so oder was meinen Sie damit?
Okay, alles gut.
Was meine ich damit, Herr Doktor?
Ich würde gerne wissen, Frau Meier, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslösung für die Schmerzen?
Nein, eigentlich gar nicht. Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen versteckt, zum Beispiel arbeiten oder das erlendert, zum Beispiel in Ruhe oder schlafen?
Das gibt mir bestimmt keine Erlendung, aber ehrlich gesagt habe ich nicht bemerkt, dass diese Schwindel besser verbessert oder verschlimmert.
Okay, Sie haben schon gesagt, die Schwindel kommt als Attack vor. Wie lange dauert eine Attacke?
Die jetzige Attacke dauert seit eineinhalb Stunden, Herr Doktor. Ich weiß nicht genau.
In eineinhalb Stunden dauert die Attacke immer dauerhaft oder währendlich.
Ich kann nicht gut verstehen, was Sie meinen, Herr Doktor, aber früher war diese Attacke kürzer als die jetzige. Vielleicht eine Stunde. Aber die jetzige Attacke dauert seit eineinhalb Stunden.
Okay, Sie sind schon einmal umgekippt oder verletzt?
Nein, Gott sei Dank. Aber ich habe nicht so etwas.
Haben Sie einmal wegen dieser Beschwerden berücksichtigt?
Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Gibt es noch einige gleichzeitig Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Kopfschmerzen, Herzschmerzen?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich habe Kopfschmerzen.
Gleichzeitig oder?
Nein, das habe ich aber schon seit vielen Jahren.
Seit vielen Jahren?
Nicht gleichzeitig, aber weil Sie danach gefragt haben, wollte ich beantworten.
Okay, ich verstehe. Wegen dieser Beschwerden waren Sie schon einmal bei Ihrem Hausarzt, oder?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Seit Langem besuche ich nicht meinen Hausarzt. Vielleicht seit zwei Jahren. Mehr als zwei Jahren war ich nicht beim Hausarzt.
Ich mag ihn nicht, Herr Doktor, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, okay, ich verstehe. Aber es ist sehr wichtig für Sie, für Ihre Gesundheit in Ihrem Hausarzt zu besuchen.
Ich habe vergessen, dass Sie auch Arzt sind. Entschuldigen Sie, bitte.
Kein Problem, machen Sie keine Sorge. Das ist nur eine Empfehlung für Sie.
Alle Regeln müssen Sie in unserem Hausarzt besuchen.
Sie haben recht.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden, z.B. Sehstörungen oder Höchststörungen?
Sehstörungen oder Höchststörungen nicht. Aber ich habe auch Übelkeit, Herr Doktor, seit drei Tagen.
Mir ist seit drei Tagen übel, aber ich habe nicht erbrochen, Herr Doktor.
Ohne erbrochen? Okay, okay.
Ich möchte wieder fragen, wie stark sind Kopfschmerzen?
Nicht so stark, vielleicht allein. Ungefähr, ja.
Auch Schmerzen, wobei nur kein Schmerzen, sehr starke Schmerzen erzielt. Wie beschreiben Sie?
Herr Doktor, ich habe es verstanden, ungefähr fünf von zehn auf beiden Seiten, Herr Doktor.
Und beide Seiten? Ja, er drückt. Auf beiden Seiten drückt.
Und drückt. Auch attackartig, oder?
Nicht immer natürlich, aber ich weiß nicht, ob er attackartig ist.
Wie ein Hämmer schlagen oder?
Er drückt nicht so stark, aber er drückt vielleicht mehr als zwei, drei Mal pro Monat. Leide ich daran.
Pro Monat, zwei, drei Mal. Aber es ist auch nicht ungesagt, seit ca. zwei Jahren haben Sie irgendwie Beschwerden.
Nein, nein. Das ist anders, Herr Doktor. Ich leide darunter seit vielen Jahren.
Diese Kopfschmerzen meine ich. Aber unter Schwindel leide ich seit zwei Jahren.
Okay, okay. Sie haben keine Sechstörungen?
Ja, Gott sei Dank. Ich kann gut sehen, ich kann gut hören.
Bis jetzt haben Sie niemals Verlust?
Ja, ja. Wie gesagt.
Ihr Leben und... Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Nein, Fieber?
Aber Herr Doktor, ich bin sehr müde. Habe wenig Appetit. Und ich möchte gar nichts essen.
Ich möchte nicht arbeiten, Herr Doktor. Ich hasse arbeiten.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Haben Sie noch... Sie haben schon gesagt, keine Herzrausen, Herzklopfen oder Erneuerungsschwerden haben?
Nein, nein. Manchmal, wenn ich Stress habe, habe ich Herzrausen, aber nicht so häufig. Sehr, sehr selten.
Okay. Haben Sie noch irgendwelche Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Herr Doktor, ich habe Verstopfung.
Verstopfung?
Ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Seit Langem habe ich Verstopfung. Dagegen muss ich manchmal...
...Affürmittel beim Dium kaufen.
Pflanzliche?
Ja, pflanzliche.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich mag nicht arbeiten. Ich mag nicht Ärzte. Ich mag nicht Medikamente, Herr Doktor.
Okay, okay. Ich verstehe Sie. Ich kann Ihnen gerne helfen.
Aber trotzdem muss ich auch Medikamente nutzen, weil ich Bluthochdruck habe, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben noch einen Bluthochdruck. Seit wann haben Sie den Bluthochdruck?
Seit etwa fünf Jahren, Herr Doktor.
Seit etwa fünf Jahren?
Ja.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen Medikamente?
Ja, leider nehme ich zwei Medikamente dagegen. Ich nehme Beloxok, Herr Doktor.
Beloxok?
Und Amlodipin.
Wie viel Medikament?
Die Dosis, soweit ich verstehe, 47,5 mg.
Okay. Und Amlodipin?
Amlodipin 5 mg.
Amlodipin?
Einmal täglich beide.
Herr Doktor, kann es sein, dass meine Medikamente mich verstopfen?
Ich glaube, seit ich das Medikament nehme, habe ich Verstopfung.
Ja, kann sein. Aber wir sollen ein paar weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Im Moment kann ich das nicht genau sagen und nicht genau wissen. Aber zum Ende können wir nach dem Untersuchungen...
Okay, wie gesagt, bin ich gedächtig. Ich kann darauf warten, kein Problem mehr.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut. Gibt es noch andere Medikamente bei Ihnen?
Außer diesen Apfelsmittel nehme ich nicht. Aber ich erinnere mich an den Namen nicht.
Okay, Apfelsmittel?
Ja, beim DM kaufe ich.
Ja, pflanzliche Apfelsmittel nehmen Sie. Okay.
Frau Meier, würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Ja Herr Doktor. Als Kind wurden mir die Mandeln entfernt und der Blinddarm.
Meine Mandeln und mein Blinddarm wurden entfernt, Herr Doktor, als ich Kind war.
Ich muss überlegen, weil ich 11 Jahre alt war, und 18 Jahre alt war, der Blinddarm.
Das war komplikationlos oder?
Nein, ich denke, alles war in Ordnung.
Okay.
Und Herr Doktor, vor etwa acht Jahren wurden mir die Gebärmutter entfernt.
Oh, sehr richtig. Danke für die Informationen. Gebärmutter entfernt vor acht Jahren?
Ich hatte diese Entfernung vor acht Jahren.
Warum wurde bei Ihnen die Gebärmutter entfernt?
Das war nicht witzig, aber wegen der Myome.
Wegen starken Blutungen musste ich das haben.
Okay, sehr gut. Sie hatten noch einen bestimmten Diagnos als Myome.
Danach hatte ich kein Problem.
Okay, alles gut. Und was mit Kaleint haben Sie schon gesagt?
Frau Meier, ich fände, dass Sie schon in Wechseljahren sind.
Ja Herr Doktor.
Seit etwa 19 Jahren.
Okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau Arztregeln?
Nach der OP war alles in Ordnung, Herr Doktor. Deswegen besuche ich nicht meinen Frau Arzt. Soll ich besuchen?
Natürlich. Um die Gebärmutter und den Brust und zum Beispiel die Aya Stöcke zu kontrollieren,
sollen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Frau Arzt besuchen.
Okay, ich mache das Herr Doktor. Danke.
Ich möchte noch einmal fragen, Frau Meier, Sie haben schon gesagt, vor acht Jahren,
dass Sie eine Gebärmutter entfernen und nur eine Gebärmutter oder Aya Stöcke, Aya Aya?
Nur eine Gebärmutter, Herr Doktor. Ist das so wichtig?
Ja, natürlich. Sehr wichtig. Frau Meier, sind Sie schon voll geimpft?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Wir haben finanzielle Probleme, deswegen muss ich immer arbeiten, obwohl ich hasse.
Ja, ich verstehe sehr gut, dass man ein bisschen schwebt.
Aber ich bin froh, dass Sie mir dabei helfen.
Ja, natürlich. Eigentlich ist für die Frührente die deutsche Renteforschung zuständig.
Aber nach dem Untersuchung mit Ihren Ergebnissen können Sie Ihren Hausarzt besuchen.
Und dann sollen Sie beim Hausarzt einen Antrag erstellen.
Ach so. Aber es dauert viel zu lange.
Leider, leider können Sie.
Und rauchen Sie, Frau Meier?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Jetzt nicht.
Vor etwa fünf Jahren habe ich nicht rauchen aufgehört.
Fünf Jahre? Sehr gut.
Aber früher habe ich etwa zehn Zigaretten halb pro Tag geraucht.
Vor fünf Jahren habe ich eine halbe Zigarette geraucht.
Aber seit fünf Jahren nicht rauchen. Sehr gut zu hören, Frau Meier.
Ich bin stolz darauf.
Ja, das ist super. Eine sehr gute Entscheidung.
Und trinken Sie mal Alkohol?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Aber nicht so viel, nur wenig. So eine Flasche Bier pro Woche.
Eine Flasche Bier pro Woche.
Und bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich diese Frage.
Haben Sie schon einmal Drogen konsumiert?
Einmal oder mehrmal habe ich nicht probiert.
Erinnern Sie sich?
Nein, einmal oder mehrmals habe ich nicht das genommen.
Frau Meier, haben Sie noch Allergie?
Ja, Herr Doktor.
Oder Staub?
Ich habe eine Nickelallergie, Herr Doktor.
Und auch nicht Flasche. Ich vertrage auch nicht Flasche.
Nickel und Flasche.
Nichts besonders brauner Flasche, Herr Doktor.
Besonders brauner Flasche. Okay.
Ich habe das notiert. Wie reagieren Sie gegen brauner oder Nickel?
Dann bekomme ich Hautausschlag und Juckreis.
Hautausschlag und Juckreis.
Frau Meier, haben Sie schon gesagt, Sie sind Bäckerin?
Ja, ich arbeite in einer Bäckerei.
Und als Kaufrau oder Bäckerin? Ich habe das als Bäckerin notiert.
Ja, ich arbeite im Hinterland.
Sie sind Herstellerin?
Alle sind Herstellerin. Ich bin beschäftigt mit Teig.
Okay, Sie sind Bäckerin. Ich verstehe.
Sie sind verheiratet und Ihr Mann ist aktuell arbeitslos.
Haben Sie Kinder? Nein, Herr Doktor.
Frau Meier, leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Mein Vater lebt noch, aber leider ist meine Mutter verstorben.
Mein Vater hatte vor fünf Jahren einen Schlaganfall, Herr Doktor.
Vater? Ja, mein Vater.
Er ist in einem Altenheim jetzt und leidet an Bluthochdruck, Herr Doktor.
Ihre Mutter ist schon verstorben?
Wir wissen nicht. Plötzlich im Bett ist sie verstorben.
Aber sie hatte auch Probleme, Herr Doktor.
Zuckerkrankheit. Und ja, Zuckerkrankheit hatte sie.
Sie war übergewichtig, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie Geschwister, Frau Meier?
Ich habe einen Bruder, Herr Doktor.
Mein Bruder hatte ein Raucherbein im Bein.
Ihm wurde ein Bein amputiert, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe Angst davor. Habe ich auch ein?
Ein Bein amputiert wegen Raucherbein. Das tut mir leid.
Nach diesem Erlebnis habe ich damit aufgehört.
Das war für mich entscheidend, mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Das ist eine sehr schlechte Erfahrung für Sie.
Aber gut, dass Sie mit dem Rauchen aufhören können.
Frau Meier, ich möchte noch einmal fragen.
Sie haben seit fünf Jahren Bluthochdruck.
Sie nehmen regelmäßig ihre Medikamente, Beloxok und Amlodipin.
Oder Sie messen den Blutdruck regelmäßig.
Zum Beispiel wie war heute Morgen?
Heute Morgen habe ich das gemessen.
Aber vor drei Tagen konnte ich das messen.
Es war 150 zu 90.
150 zu 90.
Ja. Ist das schlecht?
Das war nicht normal. Ein bisschen hoch.
Ein bisschen hoch. Okay.
Es sieht so aus, dass ich große Probleme habe.
Deswegen habe ich gefragt. Danke.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne empfehlen, Sie regelmäßig zu Hause zu besuchen.
Okay.
Ab jetzt achte ich darauf, Herr Doktor, obwohl ich ihn nicht mag.
Ja, es wäre besser für Ihre Gesundheit und für uns alle.
Frau Meier, möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie noch Fragen an mich?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Was habe ich oder was denken Sie für mich?
Frau Meier, ich habe den Versacht auf einen unkontrollierten Bluthochdruck.
Deswegen sollen wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde gerne ein wenig Blut abnehmen.
Und für das Labor die Untersuchungen durchführen.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen...
Herr Doktor, warum müssen Sie Blut abnehmen?
Wir nehmen nur ein wenig Blut, nicht so viel.
Deswegen sind Ihre Ergebnisse sehr wichtig für uns im Labor.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen, spreche ich mit meinem Oberarzt.
Dann komme ich gleich sofort zu Ihnen zurück und erzähle Ihnen Schritt für Schritt, wie es geht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ipek Kavla, möchtest du einen anderen machen?
Ja, Kling Kling.
Ja, hallo, Özyuvalı hier.
Guten Tag, ich bin Frau Ipek.
Ich rufe aus dem Labor Frau Clemens, Trombositonwert 18.500 pro Mikroliter.
18.500?
500.
Pro Mikroliter Frau Clemens.
Okay, Pro Mikroliter.
Trombositonwert, könnten Sie bitte Ihre Hausarztin weiterleiten?
Ja Frau Müller, Clemens mit S oder K?
Mit K, L, E, E, V, E, M, E, N, S.
Am Ende S.
Okay, vielen Dank Frau Müller.
Danke für die Informationsweise.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herzlich willkommen, Herr Özyuvalı.
Vielen Dank, Herr Oberarztin.
Können Sie sich kurz vorstellen?
Ja, mein Name ist Ekrem Özyuvalı.
Ich komme aus der Türkei, ich habe 43 Jahre in Deutschland gelebt.
In dieser Zeit lerne ich aktive Deutsch.
Am Anfang B1, dann B2, danach Falschprach-Pürfung, Kurs abgelegt.
Kurs gemacht, abgelegt, das heißt, das Test gemacht.
Und in der Türkei war ich als Urologer tätig.
Und dann in den letzten Jahren habe ich dreimal in einem ersten Krankenhaus hospitiert.
Ich arbeite jetzt bei der Gastronomie, Urologie und Allgemeinschirurgie.
Deswegen möchte ich wieder als Arzt in Deutschland so schnell wie möglich arbeiten.
Deswegen bin ich hier.
Warum sind Sie nach Deutschland gekommen?
Sie sind Facharzt und Sie haben viel Erfahrung in der Türkei.
Ja, aber das war ganz ungewollt wegen der Botschaft.
Das war nicht geplant.
Okay, verstehe. Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten.
Aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas Wichtiges mitteilen.
Da habe ich aus dem Labor von Frau Müller einen Anruf bekommen.
Es geht um Frau Klemers.
Die Trombositanzahl ist 18.500 Promililiter.
Promikroliter?
Ja, Promikroliter.
Die Trombositanzahl ist deutlich niedrig, wenn man die Trombositanzahle spricht.
Was ist die Ursache? Welche Ursache kann man Trombositanzahle nennen?
Es gibt drei große Ursachen.
Ich habe heute einen anderen Begriff erhalten, aber ich habe das genau vergessen.
Trombositanzahl ist eine veränderte Verbrauchung, veränderte Produktion und Immunistung.
Trombositanzahl ist eine Verbrauchung, die man in der Trombositanzahl verbreitet.
Welche Symptome erwarten Sie bei Trombositanzahl?
Meistens die Hematome, z.B. Nasenblutung, Samflreisblutung, Hinblutung.
Meistens die Blutung.
Wie können Sie die Behandlung?
Behauptung der Grunderkrankung und oder Trombostemreplasm.
Was haben Sie noch für uns heute?
Ich habe einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Er ist Henrik Mayer, 65 Jahre alt, geboren am 10.2.1959.
Er ist 1,76 Meter groß und 86,6 Kilo wiegt.
Er steht heute bei uns wegen einer 1,5 Stunden langen Astakathikaschwindeln.
Die Attacke dauert ca. 1,5 Stunden.
Er hat eine ähnliche Beschwerden in ca. 2 Jahren.
Früher waren die Beschwerden ein bisschen leicht.
In den letzten 2 Wochen sind die Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Vorher war es 2 Wochen.
Jede 2 Wochen hatte er eine Attacke.
Aber in den letzten 2 Wochen hatte er mindestens 4 Attacke pro Woche.
Er beschreibt, dass die Attacke als Anfälle kommt, die langsam aufgetreten werden.
Ich habe es schon gehört.
Ekrem, sag mal, was du noch nicht gesagt hast.
Du hast zuerst gesagt, dass Attacke jetzt ein Anfälle ist.
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Ich muss jetzt nicht mehr aufgeben.
Es ist nicht langsam, sondern es ist langsam.
Es ist nicht langsam.
Es gibt keine Auslöser.
Sie berichten auch eine dauerhaftige, seit 2 Jahren andauernde, beide Seiten drückende Kopfschmerzen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 von 10 auf einer Schmerzskala.
Die Schmerzen treten auf 2 oder 3 Mal pro Monat.
Sie glaubt über Übelkeit, ohne Erbrüche.
Sie beschreibt eine Inappetanz.
Sie schläft gut?
Ich habe diese Frage nicht gefragt.
In der letzten Zeit hat sie gewicht abgenommen oder so genommen?
Gewicht war los, aber ich habe es nicht vergessen.
Inappetanz ist, dass du die Inappetanz nicht vergessen kannst.
Gewicht ist, dass du es nicht vergessen kannst.
Das ist eine Begründung der Vegetative-Syndrom.
Gewicht war ausgesprochen.
Das kann nicht für alle Menschen wichtig sein.
Das ist auch wichtig für uns.
Das ist wichtig für die Symptome der Vegetative-Syndrom.
Bei der Vorerkrankung erwähnte sie eine arteriöle Hypertonie seit 5 Jahren.
Dagegen nimmt sie regelmäßig Beloxokon 47,5 mg und Amlodipin 5 mg.
Sie hatte eine unkontrollierte arteriöle Hypertonie.
Sie war 3 Tage lang in der letzten Messung.
Das war 150 Jahre lang.
Das war 15 Jahre lang.
Wie viel war das?
1.000 mHg.
Bei der Voroperation an Amnese erwähnte sie bei ihr mit 18. Lebensjahr eine Transylektomie.
Mit 15. Lebensjahr wurde eine Appendektomie durchgeführt.
Vor 8 Jahren wurde bei ihr eine Hystereptomie durchgeführt.
Die Diagnose war Myoma Uteri.
Das war komplikationlos und pathologisch befinden nicht böse Artikel.
Sie berichtet auch.
Sie hat eine Nickelallergie und eine braune Pflasterallergie.
Sie reagierte auf Hautausschlag und Juckreis.
Was ist der Fachbegriff Hautausschlag?
Ja, das ist die Püretis und Ertem.
Püretis und Ertem reagiert auf Püretis und Ertem.
Ja, das ist die Hautrötung.
Hautausschlag, Exanthem.
Hautrötung, Ertem.
Hautausschlag.
Ausschlag, Exanthem.
Ja, das ist die Haut.
Und dann verwendet.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Sie sind seit 19 Jahren in Wechseljahr.
Keine Regelmäßigfrau an Ars besucht hat.
Sie ist nicht rauchen seit 5 Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren wurde eine halbe Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag konsumiert.
Ein Flasche Bier...
Wie lange hat sie geraucht?
Habe ich nicht gefragt.
Wegen frag ich.
Wenn ich mit dem Rauchen aufhöre, das freut mich sehr.
Leider habe ich diese Fragen vergessen.
Ich kann verstehen.
Ein Flasche Bier pro Woche würde Beat und Drogenkonsum verneint.
Die Familien an Amnesie ergaben sich Schlaganfall.
Was ist Schlaganfall?
Apoplex und arteriöre Hypertonik beim Vater.
Die Mutter ist plötzlich verstorben.
Die Gründe waren unbekannt.
Die Diabetes Typ 2 war bei der Mutter bekannt.
Was könnte der Mutter für die Ursache sein?
Die Diabetes mellitus?
Die Ursache könnte Hyperglycemie sein.
Wegen Atteriskleros oder Schlaganfall oder Apoplex.
Wegen Atteriskleros?
Ja, wegen Atteriskleros.
Das könnte auch Myokartinfarkt sein.
Ja, Myokartinfarkt.
Ich habe damals die Erfahrung gelesen.
Ein Teilnehmer hat diese Fragen bekommen.
Die Antwort ist Myokartinfarkt.
Am Anfang, wie soll ich das sagen?
Alle Vermutungen sind richtig, aber der häufigste ist ...
Ja, häufigste.
Man sollte immer am häufigsten denken.
Er hat einen Bruder.
Der Bruder hat einen rauhen Bein.
Was ist Fachbegriff?
Perfekt arterial Verschlusskrankheit.
Bei Feuerkrankungen, Familienanamnesen usw.
Sagen Sie Fachbegriff.
Ja, ja.
Und Perfekt arterial Verschlusskrankheit.
Daran, die einen Bein anbietet.
Sind Sie Bäckerin?
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Jemand ist aktuell arbeitslos?
Sie ist Bäckerin, Sie sind nicht. Sie ist Bäckerin.
Sie ist Bäckerin, sie ist verheiratet.
Jemand ist arbeitslos.
Sie hat keine Kinder.
Das war's.
Was ist der Verdacht, Jakunsel?
Ich habe den Verdacht auf eine unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie.
Was bedeutet unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie?
Unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie oder eine unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie.
Unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie ist genug.
Aber was bedeutet unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie?
Wie können Sie verschreiben? Wie können Sie erklären?
Sie hatte Schwindelattacken.
Seit zwei Jahren war sie nicht im Hausarzt.
Die nächste Messung war drei Tage.
150 zu 90 Millimeter Hg.
Sie nimmt regelmäßig ihre Medikamente.
Aber aus meiner Sicht passt die Dosis nicht.
Sie hat seit zwei Jahren Kopfschmerzen und Atakartgeschwindel.
Deswegen habe ich eine unkontrollierte Arterialhypertonie gedacht.
Sie misst ihren Blutdruck nicht regelmäßig.
Ja. Die letzte Messung war ...
Sie weiß nur, wie hoch die letzte Messung war.
Ja.
Ja. Weiter?
Weiter ...
Wer hat die Differenz der Diagnose in Betracht?
Als Diagnose kommen eine Hypothese und ein Burnout-Syndrom.
Und wofür spricht das?
Sie beschwert, aber sie habe alleine gearbeitet.
Ihr Mann ist arbeitslos.
Ihr wollt nie weiter arbeiten.
Ihr wollt früh in die Rente gehen.
Sie beschreibt seit zwei Jahren Atakartgeschwindel und Kopfschmerzen.
Leider habe ich nicht gefragt, ob sie Schlafstörungen haben.
Ja. Deswegen.
Okay.
Und noch andere Beschwerden sind die Hypothese.
Sie bietet dafür Kraftverlust und Erschöpfung.
Kraftverlust?
Ja.
Leidet sie an Kraftverlust?
Leidet unter dauerhafter Erschöpfung.
Ja. Aber Kraftverlust bedeutet Muskelschwache.
Muskelschwache. Ja.
Ich habe es vorhin gesagt.
Sie hatte dauerhafter Erschöpfung.
Und Inappetanz und Verstopfung.
Ja. Kopfschmerzen.
Okay.
Welche Diagnostik möchten Sie durchführen?
Als erstens würde ich gerne einen Körperversuch durchführen.
Dann würde ich ein Blut für das Labor abnehmen.
Im Labor würde das Blutbild, Leber und Nieren werden.
Und Brutensime.
T3, T4 und TCH.
GGB und so weiter.
Das ist das, was ich vorhin gesagt habe.
Und dann...
Herr, das ist richtig.
Was kann man mit der Diagnostik von der Apparatur hören?
Bankseite. Das ist eine Inbechtigungseite.
Die Regeln müssen die Blutdruck messen.
Ja. Langsamer.
Eine Inruhe EKG.
Und Blutdruck messen.
Schilddürse unternehmen. Ja.
Das ist richtig.
Keine Inruhe EKG.
Das kann man mit der Apparatur nicht durchführen.
Was ist denn die Differenz der Dschungel?
Das ist etwas, was man mit der Apparatur nicht durchführen kann.
Natürlich werde ich eine EKG schreiben und als Apparativ werde ich eine langsätzliche
Blutdruckmessung auf Schittdrüse Ultraschall durchführen.
Ich werde einen Konsil in der Abteilung für Kardiologie und Psychiatrie anfordern.
Zum Beispiel, so kannst du es sagen.
Ja, eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung, eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung,
eine Schittdrüse Ultraschall durchführen und eine Kardiologie und eine Endokrinologie
durchführen.
Mhm.
Langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung, ich weiß nicht, ob du das richtig hast.
Eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das richtig hast.
Eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung, eine Schittdrüse Ultraschall durchführen und eine
Schittdrüse Ultraschall durchführen.
Ja, das kannst du auch sagen.
Aber eine Blutdruckmessung muss man sich die Belastung von Blutdruckmessungen
ausüben.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie tragen eine kleine Schere für die Blutdruckmessung.
Ja, das habe ich schon erinnert.
Eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung.
Das ist eine Blutdruckautomatische Mermassmiss.
Da gibt es eine genaue Belkbekommen.
Es gibt eine schöne Erklärung, was ich mit dem Thema mache.
Ich bin ein bisschen ein Freund.
Ich nehme...
Sie können diese Frage erst einmal wiederholen.
Langsätzliche Blutdruckmessungen?
Nein, nein, Ice-Aparativ.
Ich würde gerne eine regelmäßige Blutdruckmessung und eine langsätzliche Blutdruckmessung
durchführen und eine Schittdrüse Ultraschall durchführen.
Dann werde ich eine kardologische und eine schädliche Ultraschallmessung durchführen.
Wenn meine Diagnose bestimmt ist, würde ich gerne diese Patientenambulanz behandeln.
Werde ich diese Patientenambulanz behandeln?
Ja, das würde ich gerne.
Ich empfehle Ihnen eine regelmäßige Blutdruckmessung und eine Lebensstelleveränderung.
Und eine Ernährungsanstellung und eine Patientenschulung.
Wie kann ich Sie beantworten?
Die Patienten können die Patientenambulanz behandeln.
Die Medikamente, die gegen arteriöle Bluthochdruck angenommen werden,
werden nicht so gut ausgerichtet.
Wenn die Patientenambulanz nicht gut ausgerichtet wird,
werden sie nicht so gut ausgerichtet.
Die Medikamente, die gegen arteriöle Bluthochdruck angenommen werden,
werden nicht so gut ausgerichtet.
Die Anamnesen von Bernold-Syndrom sind wirklich schwierig.
Man ist so enttäuscht, wenn so etwas wie Schwindel kommt.
Wir gehen immer mit 10 Bakal-Anamnesen.
Ich habe das gut gearbeitet, aber ich kann es nicht beweisen.
Schwindel hat keine Anamnesen.
Ich habe die erste Frage gestellt, ob es schon mal eine Art Artik ist.
Dann habe ich die gleiche Artik auch in der V-Range.
Und ich kann auch noch 4 Fragen stellen.
Ich kann also nur 4 Fragen stellen.
Können Sie den Schwindel genabe Schreiben?
Wie Botfahren oder wie Karusel?
Ich kann nur 4 Fragen stellen.
Ich kann also nur 4 Fragen stellen.
Ist es eine Auslöse?
Artik?
Das kannst du auch fragen, wenn du das nicht sagst.
Aber generell sagt man es selbst.
Ist es eine Art Artik?
Ist es erst mal?
Hat es schon früher eine Symptome?
Können Sie den Schwindel genabe Schreiben?
Natürlich, weil es schon vorhanden ist,
fragen wir alle, die schon vorhanden sind,
was sie sagen.
Wie ist es, wenn es erst mal ist?
Aber Schwindel hat 4 Fragen.
Wie lange ein Schlaf dauert,
kann es genabe Schreiben,
hat es schon vorhanden,
hat es eine Auslöse?
Schwindel ist das.
Wenn du das fragst,
ist Schwindel schon vorbei.
Dann gibt es Schwindel,
weil es ein neurologischer Symptom ist,
dann gibt es ein paar Neurologische Fragen.
Dann gibt es ein paar Neurologische Fragen.
Du hast sie schon gefragt.
Habensie, Kopschi, Mertzsen.
Jetzt glaube ich, Bird
ist nie wieder dabei.
Du kannst oft Cape הע,
das kannst du dazu fragen.
Wenn du largest Schwindel findest,
können Sie es twice brighten.
Wie die Wichtaxe und die Schmerzen.
Wo, Wan, Tarif,
also Veganal,
Besrecht,
Wichtaxe.
Ich habe diese gefragt.
Soviel.
Es ist sehr leicht,
also keine Anmerkungen.
Ich habe das für das hier gesagt.
Die Analyse des Burnout Syndrome ist wirklich schwierig,
aber wenn du eine Systematik in deinem Kopf hast,
wirst du nicht verletzen.
Es braucht viel Zeit, um zu verletzen.
Es gibt 3-4 Fragen um die Schwindel.
Die Schmerzen sind leicht,
also nur 4-5 Fragen.
Dann ist es leicht,
zu verletzen,
oder zu verletzen,
dass sie Lämmer,
Krebsgefühl,
Type-8-Gefühl,
oder sie sind verletzt,
oder sie sind umgekippt.
So ein paar Fragen.
Dann ist es vorbei.
Dann geht es um Amnesie.
Ich würde es meinen,
dass es nicht so gut ist,
die Schmerzen in den Schmerzen des Standard-Dürsel-4 zu verletzen.
Aber die Fragen sind definitiv.
Erst die Schwindel,
dann die Kopfschmerzen,
dann die Begleitung,
die sie auf die Schmerzen aufsetzen.
Die anderen haben keine Frage.
Da gibt es keine Frage.
Da gibt es die Schmerzen.
Danke, Frau.
Du hast dich sehr gut um die Prüferung der Körpereignung, Ekrem.
Du prüferst sehr schnell,
sehr genau.
Du prüferst sehr schnell.
Du prüferst sehr spontan.
Wie war die Zeit, Frau?
Wie war die Zeit?
Ich habe die Zeit nicht bemerkt.
Ich kann die Zeit nicht beherrschen.
Das ist das neue.
Die Zeit ist heute etwas zu lang.
Diese Fragen haben 26-27 Minuten gedauert.
Die Patientin hatte auch sehr viele Reaktionen,
weil sie sich um sie verabschiedet hat.
Und wenn Schwindel kam,
haben Sie sich etwas verabschiedet.
Da sind die Fragen zuerst ein bisschen zusammen.
Schwindel und Aarhus-Fragen.
Ich möchte die Vorwürfe der IP-Kabellinien nicht beantworten.
Wir werden nach der Vorwürfe sprechen.
Wie wir die Tage machen.
Die IP-Kabellinien, bitte.
Ich möchte heute nicht mehr.
Ich konnte das Thema nicht beantworten.
Okay.
Danke.
Dann ist es so.
Wer möchte sich eine Frage an diesen Vorwürfen stellen?
Ich sage es nicht, um zu sprechen.
Aber wenn Sie etwas fragen,
dann bitte.
Ich möchte Sie nicht beantworten.
Aber wenn Sie es nicht wissen,
dann stellen Sie uns diese Frage.
Was werden Sie fragen?
Schwindel ist wirklich ein Ort,
in dem ich nicht ausgehen kann.
Ich kann nicht ausgehen.
Nein, niemand kann sich davon ausgehen.
Schwindel hat vier, fünf Fragen.
Das ist alles.
Ich möchte Sie fragen.
Schwindel hat eine Woche.
Sie kommen in die Woche.
Wenn Sie das nicht sagen,
dann können Sie das fragen.
Sie haben eine Woche.
Das ist alles.
Es gibt keine weitere Frage.
Sie haben eine Woche.
Das ist alles.
Schwindel hat vier, fünf Fragen.
Herr Schwindel, kann Sie uns ein bisschen
fürstehendok machen?
Kann Sie uns ein bisschen
Ja, wir werden
die weitere Erklärung
mit dem Widerstand
überprüfen und Blut für das Labo abnehmen
und eine EKG schreiben.
Im Labo werde ich Blutbild,
Entzündung Parameter,
SR-Aktivprotein,
Nierenwerte, Labowerte,
Elektronikteinwerte,
und Ferritin,
Transferrin,
Beswölf und Foligsäure
auf
Troid
Schilddrüse Parameter
TSH, Frit3,
Frit4
bestimmen lassen.
Als Apparativ werde ich
Schilddrüse
Ultraschall
durchführen.
Schilddrüse Ultraschall
Ich werde
einen Konzil in der Abteilung
für
Psychiatrie
anfordern.
Leberstilveränderung
spielt hier eine große Rolle.
Die Arbeitsbelastung
zu reduzieren
Gewicht
so reduzieren, Gewicht so reduzieren, regelmäßige Sportstreiben auf psychologisches Konzül kann
dieser Patienten helfen. An kontrollierte Hypertonide, die Medikamente, die gegen arterial
Bluthochdruck angenommen werden, sollte angepasst werden.